in 1982 Ridley Scott's tech-noir classic
Blade Runner was met with skeptical
audiences and empty theatres thanks in
part to a series of slapdash changes
made after low test screening scores
panicked the studio but now alternative
versions of the movie more in line with
the directors original vision are widely
available to curious viewers as a result
the film's popularity has risen steadily
over the years along with a lot of
burning questions no seriously
is he Blade Runner depicts a near future
in which androids
known as replicants are so advanced that
they're virtually indistinguishable from
the real thing and most of the debates
surrounding the film centers on whether
its hero Rick Deckard played by Harrison
Ford is a human or a replicant let's try
to make some sense of it all the origami
unicorn
so is replicant hunter Rick Deckard
actually an Android this scene suggests
the answer is a definite yes after
dreaming of a unicorn earlier in the
film Deckard finds & fondles this
origami version which must have been
made by our guardo gaff the veteran LAPD
Blade Runner and origami maker who
orders Deckard around but Deckard isn't
exactly the type to open up to his
co-workers about his nighttime fantasies
which means the only way gaff could
possibly know Deckard dreams about
unicorns is that he somehow read
Deckard's memory file and if there's one
thing we learned throughout this movie
it's that gaff is creepy who delivers
Deckard's LAPD summons at a dirty noodle
bar gaff and creeps up behind Deckard as
soon as he retires the first of his
assigned targets yeah who shows up
immediately after Nexus six replicant
Roy batty empties the contents of his
soul in the pouring rain gaff and who
knows all about Deckard secret unicorn
dreams come on don't make us say it
again it's pretty clear that LAPD
veteran gaff is monitoring Deckard why
would this so-called one-man
slaughterhouse need a leash maybe
because he's a replicant only like the
film's femme fatale Rachael he doesn't
know it who's the man Edoardo gaff also
drops one major hint that our Blade
Runner hero might not be a human after
all
after he's completed his mission in a
surprising climactic moment
then immense job this is one of the most
dissected debated lines in the film's
history and for good reason if you want
to praise a guy for a job well done it's
kind of a weird choice of words right
that is unless the man in question isn't
a man at all but a robot in which case
it's a heck of a compliment and a good
way to tip off your audience as to
Deckard's true nature in case they
hadn't figured it out yet
the directors take at this point the
evidence seems to be piling up that
Deckard is indeed a replicant and we
haven't even mentioned how he survives
through multiple battles that would
probably leave an ordinary person in
several pieces or the split second where
his eyes seemed to flash with the
otherworldly glow that's unique to the
film's replicant characters but since
nobody knows the truth better than the
man who made the movie it probably makes
the most sense to just ask him Ridley
Scott has already said that when it
comes to the Deckard question if you
don't get it you're a [ __ ] but in an
interview with Wired he went into detail
for all of us morons saying that's the
whole point of gaff the guy who makes
origami and leaves little matchstick
figures around
he doesn't like Deckard and we don't
really know why if you take for granted
for a moment that let's say Deckard is a
Nexus 7 he probably has an unknown
lifespan and therefore is starting to
get awfully human but wait there's more
so Rick Deckard is a replicant has
always been a replicant and will always
be a replicant right well not so fast
the dissenting opinion on that front is
none other than Harrison Ford who says
he and Ridley Scott were always at odds
over Deckard's true nature so I resisted
the idea of being a replicant Ford felt
that blade runner's audience should have
a human character to connect with and in
the original theatrical cut of the film
which was missing some of the key scenes
that brought Deckard's humanity into
question
Ford's interpretation makes more sense
but when the director says Deckard is a
replicant and the guy who plays Deckard
says he's not it's hard to know who to
believe until you remember that Deckard
is ostensibly a robot who only thinks
he's a person which means that Ford's
insistence otherwise could just be a
genius bit of method acting the more he
shares his character's delusions the
reload of the film right right the
question is the answer
pretty much everyone involved in Blade
Runner has an opinion on the is he or
isn't he debating about Rick Deckard
but author philip k dick who wrote the
book the movie was based on should get
the last word and according to dick the
M
guity surrounding Deckard's humanity and
more broadly surrounding whether there's
any real difference between humans and
replicants is kind of the whole point
it's a replicant who saves Deckard's
life and delivers the film's most
poignant lines before dying with grace
and dignity when the replicant show more
empathy than the men who created them
which one of them is more human what do
the insights of a robot tell us about
the meaning of existence they're just
questions Leon
in other words Blade Runner is designed
to make you think bigger about the
nature of life itself whether you're
human or something more thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]